[Musica]
d
qualche mese fa sono andata a roma per
lavoro
devo parlare non conferenza della
microfinanza microfinanza è il fatto di
poter finanziare indirettamente dei
microimprenditori in tutto il mondo
andavo per spiegare cosa fa la nostra
istituzione
in questo campo e ho prenotato un
albergo che mi era stato consigliato a
roma
molto bello quindi arrivo alla reception
e antonio nobel e titola camera in quel
momento signora le reception mi dice
guardi ci spiace tantissimo la sua
stanza a due letti singoli
ecco guardi non c'è nessun problema sono
qua per lavoro sono il sole va benissimo
ma va veramente a un grandissimo
problema ci dispiace e da quel momento
uno scambio di qualche minuto su questo
tema io ogni volta dai media la chiave
prendo la chiave generata entrò in
camera è la stupenda bellissimo soffitti
alti pazzeschi pulita bellissima è un
letto immenso metto lì le cose
scendo e prima di andare alla conferenza
e dico guardia signore si è sbagliato
questa camera e bellissima un letto ma
simone adesso strepitoso sorpresa è più
bello per una bella sorpresa che una
brutta sorpresa è vero sì grazie
vado felice alla conferenza spiego cosa
facciamo noi con la microfinanza
voi pensate che microfinanza voler
finanziare persone che sono nei paesi in
via di sviluppo in india vietnam costa
d'avorio sud africa colombia
pensate così sì ma non solo microfinanza
vuol dire finanziare non solo progetti
piccoli ma vuol dire finanziare persone
che non sono incluse finanziariamente
persone che non riescono ad ottenere
credito microfinanza c'è anche in
francia in belgio
in italia in lussemburgo persino
lussemburgo in italia il più grande
attore si chiama permicro eroga 40
milioni di crediti ogni anno a 30.000
clienti dalla sua origine poco più di
dieci anni fa hanno erogato 200 milioni
di crediti a persone a famiglie e
imprenditori
pensate che queste famiglie che hanno
trovato lavoro in questo modo queste
imprese che sono riuscite a essere
finanziate a crearsi trasformarsi in
questo tempo hanno personale hanno
versato allo stato italiano tra
contributi tasse o contributi non
ricevuti hanno riversato 100 milioni di
euro
non è poco questa è una cifra enorme ma
non solo hanno fatto di inclusione
finanziaria tra le famiglie che sono
state finanziate tra queste famiglie 60
per cento dopo il primo finanziamento di
permicro ha trovato un finanziamento
bancario cioè è entrato nella finanza
tradizionale
dopo la conferenza attorno all'albergo a
dormire la mattina dopo
prima colazione prima colazione chiedo
un cappuccino con tanta schiuma come
piace a me mi siedo arriva un ragazzo
con un sudario un cappuccino un caffè mi
dà il caffè e lo guardi scusi anche sul
cappuccino penso che sia quello lì
no no guardi sono sicuro che health è
che il caffè in quel momento un altro
cliente accanto dice guardi io ho
chiesto il caffè quindi forse quelle
quello mio e a questo punto che sto
ragazzo
guardo il caffè cosa cappuccino ma certo
allora il cappuccino per lei il caffè
per lei tutti i problemi si risolvono né
vita è così bella
è vero la vita è bella sapete chi erano
queste persone questo è il personale
dell'albergo etico albergo etico che uno
dei tre alberghi di questo tipo in
italia e assume persone che sono uscite
dal coma o persone
quando la sindrome di down la trisomia
21 e le assume in forma al mese del
turismo
pensate che in italia tra le persone
quella sindrome di down solo 18 per
cento hanno un lavoro stabile e tra i
beneficiari dell'albergo etico sono il
68 per cento cano lavoro stabile e
albergo etico in albergo fao albergo è
molto bello
vi consiglio comunque dopo vado negli
uffici della nostra filiale roma bnl e
dobbiamo parlare di economia circolare
dobbiamo fare un articolo sulla
pubblicazione si fanno sapere quali
società valorizzare in climi parlano
della cooperativa sociale risorse una
copertina sociale che con 70 persone e
che maggiormente i giovani con disagio
riesce a recuperare ogni anno 24 mila
tonnellate di rifiuti e 70 per cento
viene valorizzato di cooperative sociali
questo tipo c'è soltanto in italia sono
molto bravi e poi parliamo anche delle
tech for good le start up tekfor
goodrich cioè le società nuove giovani
che fanno usa la tecnologia usano il
digitale per far del bene e ce ne sono
tante sempre di più sempre di più fatte
da giovane ma giornata e quindi parliamo
per esempio di eccovi una società che in
francia che fa un car sharing un po
diverso un condividere macchi in modo
diverso lavora con i comuni delle zone
periferiche regioni montagna delle zone
rurali e vede dove ci sono dove ci sono
percorsi congestionati o dove c'è
bisogno di inserire una linea pubblica
si mette i proprietari
entrano sul sito e creano ed hanno a
disposizione loro macchia sui loro
percorsi e per qualche minuto la loro
macchina privata diventa un mezzo
pubblico di trasporto un impatto
ambientale fantastico diminuzione di
diossido di carbonio un impatto sociale
importante perché dà mobilità a coloro
che non hanno la macchina
e anche un impatto di diminuire il
traffico che la meta e poi ci sono
ancora altre tech for good ci sono anche
nell'alimentazione questa ci toccherà
ancora più da vicino
sapete che 30 per cento del cibo che
viene motivi hai prodotto non arriva sui
nostri piatti
non lo compriamo ma non è solo il cibo
più
peggio di così è anche tutto quello che
occorre per produrlo l'acqua l'energia
il trasporto i semi tempo del lavoro 30
per cento ha buttato via uno spreco e ci
sono società come felix dhx è in francia
che anche questa startup che ormai
esiste da qualche anno e che ha creato
un sito e una logistica per far in modo
che i negozianti di cibo di prodotti
alimentari possano venderli a basso
prezzo prima della scadenza o proprio
giusto giusto conoscano e che se lo sono
venduti poi li dà anche alle
associazioni caritative fenix per
esempio distribuisce ogni ogni giorno
120 mila pasti
l'anno scorso ha distribuito 40 milioni
di pasti tradotto in euro 70 milioni di
euro quindi vedete subito l'impatto
ambientale positivo che ha creato e le
persone che hanno consumato per chi vi
parla di tutto questo che cosa hanno in
comune queste società
il settore avete capito no sono settori
diversi e la ragione sociale no perché
sono cooperative sociali o associazioni
o società di capitali sono sì tutti i
clienti del nostro gruppo che finanziamo
loro ma finanziamo la società di questo
tipo anche per 2 miliardi di euro e
anche andiamo 2.500 clienti di questo
tipo ma non è questo il punto comune
hanno in comune il fatto che tutte hanno
messo il bene comune
l'obiettivo di creare di sviluppare di e
di risolvere un problema sociale
hanno messo sullo stesso piano che
l'obiettivo di guadagnare di fare utili
sono da tutte inutile o quasi in ricky
van tutte vogliono lavorare su un
problema sociale o ambientale
queste sono imprese sociali social
business hanno la forza dentro sono il
loro i loro imprenditori i loro creatori
viene vengono chiamati changemakers sud
e visionari che cambiano il futuro
queste sono le imprese che stanno
emergendo sempre di più e ciò che
vogliamo che emerga da questa crisi
ed è ciò che riuscirà a risolvere
l'emergenza perché loro stanno mettendo
tutta la loro forza tutta la loro forza
in questa missione e ce la fanno perché
guadagnano solo questo il messaggio che
vogliamo che vogliamo condividere questi
imprenditori non sono soli sono inseriti
in un ecosistema di finanziatore di
investitori incubatori e acceleratori
accompagnatori mentor non solo soli e
non devono essere lasciati soli
devono essere accompagnate quindi
dobbiamo avere la forza di creare come
come società di questo tipo di
accompagnarle di farle crescere perché
stanno risolvendo dei problemi stanno
creando un nuovo paradigma una nuova
norma di impresa e quella che noi
pensiamo che sarà il futuro e sarà un
futuro che cambierà che migliorerà il
nostro futuro quello del pianeta è
quello delle prossime generazioni
grazie
[Musica]